[Applause]
what's gucci y'all
we out here living that lavish life
racks on racks on rack let's get this
money yeah
when i go out to eat
i take a private jet mansions around the
world i ain't even been to yet money's
so tall it's in the nba i'm a black
billionaire with more stacks than yay
we our own bank pay for everything in
cash but still with all this cheddar
we can't afford gas
[Music]
we can't afford gas
these prices are high we can't afford
gas
[Music]
we can't afford gas oh let me tell you
something money like magic mother
but it ain't no trick though you got to
have that vote to be in my click though
i see a cutie that i like imma say hop
on the back on the back of my bike
garage filled to the brim i got cars out
the ass and that's where they'll stay
cause
i can't afford gas
how much
can't afford that how much is a city
fight damn it the
[Music]
so my favorite chain to drive to the
grocery store i left the car there i
don't need it anymore no more driving i
survive i don't care how i brought a
pillowcase to work cause i live there
now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you two are out on your ass
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you